Professor Ben Polak: All
right, so last time we were
talking about The Investor Game
and this was a coordination
game,
and we learned some things.
I just want to recall some of
the things we learned so I can
highlight them a bit.
One thing we learned was that
communication can help in a
coordination game.
So I forget who it was,
but someone down here who has
disappeared, was our Jimmy
Stewart character and helped
coordinate you on a better
equilibrium simply by suggesting
what you should do.
There are two lessons here.
One is this is very different
from the Prisoner's Dilemma.
So we learned the very first
time that in the Prisoner's
Dilemma communication per se
won't help,
but in the coordination
problem, which could be just as
serious socially as a Prisoner's
Dilemma,
in a coordination problem it
may well help.
The reason it helps is you're
trying to coordinate onto a Nash
Equilibrium.
One way to think about Nash
Equilibria is that they are
self-enforcing agreements,
so provided that everyone
believes that everyone is going
to go along with this agreement,
then everyone in fact will.
I want to make another,
slightly more philosophical
remark associated with this and
it's to do with the idea of
"leadership."
So leadership is kind of a big
word that you see written
probably too often these days,
in too many newspaper articles,
and it probably comes up in too
many Yale classes,
and I don't claim to know
anything about leadership.
And I don't think Game Theory
is going to contribute to
anything to understanding about
leadership.
But one thing we can do is tell
you where leadership may help.
In the coordination game,
where the idea is to try and
get people to coordinate on a
particular equilibria rather
than on another equilibria,
or worse still,
to be uncoordinated entirely.
In those kind of games,
leadership can help
tremendously.
A little bit of leadership can
help tremendously.
So these games,
these coordination games,
are games where there is a
"scope for leadership."
Just to see that in a very
simple example,
again, we don't use such a
complicated example as the one
we looked at last time,
you could imagine a game,
a really trivial coordination
game, which looked like this
(1,1) (0,0) (0,0) (1,1).
And clearly in this game what
matters is coordinating.
You either want to coordinate
on up left or you want to
coordinate on down right.
You don't want to end up
uncoordinated on down left or up
right.
Everyone see that?
So in this game if you just
played it, it's quite likely
you're going to end up
uncoordinated,
but if you have a little bit of
leadership can say okay let's
make sure this is where we
coordinate,
or let's make sure this is
where we coordinate.
So this matters a lot.
And I don't want to overplay
the social importance of this,
but go back a couple of years
to what was happening in the
aftermath of Katrina and realize
how important--how bad things
get when things fail to be
coordinated.
One other remark before we
leave this, in the game we
played last time,
in the investment game,
one feature of that game was
that the more you thought other
people were going to invest,
the more you wanted to invest.
The more you thought other
people were going to invest,
the more likely that you were
going to invest.
If you go back to the time
before that, we talked about
this partnership game.
In the partnership game you
were contributing effort to a
joint project.
It could have been a law firm;
it could have been working in
the study group on a homework
assignment.
In that game,
if you remember what the best
responses looked like,
they looked like this where
this was the effort of Player 1;
this was the effort of Player 2.
This was the best response of
Player 1 and this was the best
response of Player 2.
This game also has the feature
that the more effort the other
person--the more the other
person does--the more you want
to do.
The more effort your partner
provides into this project the
more effort you want to provide
in this project.
I just want to introduce a bit
of jargon here.
These games in which the more
the other person does the more I
want to do, these are called
games of strategic complements.
These are games of strategic
complements.
So both the investment game and
the game with--the partnership
firm game are games with
strategic complements.
We could call the strategies
We'll come back to this later
on today.
So before we leave coordination
games, I want to look at another
one, a little bit more
complicated one perhaps,
that we mentioned briefly last
time.
So we'll look at and play
another game,
and we'll call this game,
"Going to the Movies."
So I always regard one purpose
of this class to help hapless
Yale students in their dating
strategies.
That seems like a good thing to
do.
How many of you are Econ majors?
There's a lot of people who
probably need a lot of help with
their dating strategies,
right?
Okay, so the idea of this game
is a couple is going to meet up
at the movies.
And let's have a look at the
movies concerned here and we'll
draw--there's three possible
movies.
The movies we're going to look
at are The Bourne
Ultimatum,
and the movie called Good
Shepherd,
and a movie called Snow
White and I'll explain the
game in more detail in a second.
Now, it used to be in the old
days before I had kids,
I could list off 15 current
movies and help you a bit more
with your dating strategy by
giving you instant movie
reviews,
but now I have kids,
I get to see precisely two
movies a year,
and the two movies I got to see
this year were The Bourne
Ultimatum and the Good
Shepherd. And now I think
about it,
both of those have Matt Damon
in it.
My wife chose both so maybe I
need to work out some more.
So just to give you some idea
about these movies,
how many of you saw Bourne
Ultimatum?
Quite a lot of you;
this is a movie,
it has pretty good action,
virtually no plot.
Basic lesson of this movie
is--if you take home a
lesson--it's that all spies are
psychos or something like that.
Then how many of you saw
Good Shepherd?
A lot of you saw that as well.
It's actually pretty good.
It has a lot of plot and no
action, so it's the other way
around.
The basic lesson of this movie
is--and you probably knew this
already--everyone at Yale is a
spy … and by the way also
a psycho.
The third movie is Snow
White, which I haven't gone
out to see but my four-year old
daughter has seen on 24 of the
last 27 nights on video.
And this movie,
I don't know if I would
recommend it that much,
it's--perhaps I'm being too
PC--but I'm not convinced that
for the modern woman,
hanging around waiting for your
prince to come is really a good
strategy.
By the way, for those of
you--those of you who are,
if you are doing that strategy,
got me in trouble.
Never mind, if you are doing
that strategy,
take it from a Brit,
most princes are as dumb as
toast, not worth waiting for.
So let's put the payoffs in
here.
So the idea here is that these
people are going to meet at the
movie, they're going to go out
to a movie.
And they've decided to go to
the Criterion [New Haven movie
theatre], or the local movie
house,
and there were these three
movies showing,
and they're all excited about
going to this movie except being
Economics majors and not very
good at dating,
they have forgotten to tell
each other which movie they're
actually going to go to.
They're going to meet in there
on the--in the back row probably
and--but they're not telling us
which movie.
So that's a problem and let's
put in the payoffs,
and we'll put in the payoffs
that roughly I think would
correspond--so my preferences
and we'll talk about it--what
these preferences mean in a
second.
So here we go so …
-1,( -1,0), (-1,0),
(-2, -2).
So here are the preferences for
these movies of Player 1 and
Player 2, and you can see from
these preferences,
from these payoffs,
that the best thing for Player
1 is for both players,
both people to meet and go to
the Bourne Ultimatum;
this is the action movie.
So it's not to be
sexist--assume this is the she
and this is the he,
so she would like to go and see
Matt Damon beat people up and
coordinate on that,
her favorite thing.
And she gets nothing if they
fail to coordinate and so on and
so forth.
Her second choice is to manage
to coordinate at Matt Damon
being a Yale spy,
and then she really doesn't
want to go and see Snow
White, and the worst thing
of all,
actually this is for both
players, the worst thing of all
is to coordinate with Snow
White because then you've
got to talk about it afterwards
at Koffee [New Haven
café].
Same thing with the other
person.
Same thing exactly,
except that he would rather
meet at the Good
Shepherd. Since he's a Yale
guy,
he probably thinks of himself
as the Matt Damon character
though perhaps not,
and failing that,
he'd like to coordinate at the
Bourne Ultimatum.
But again, the disaster is to
fail to coordinate and go to see
different movies.
So these are the preferences.
What can we tell immediately,
if you're stuck in this
situation?
What can you tell immediately
about this game?
What's an easy first step?
Let's get the guy in the red
here.
Student: Snow
White is dominated by both
players.
Professor Ben Polak:
Good, so for both players
Snow White is a dominated
strategy.
So both players having taken
this class--I told you it would
help you with your dating.
So both players will realize
that they should at least not go
to Snow White,
is that right?
Great animation but not perhaps
a good date movie,
so it's gone.
Everyone see that?
So that leaves us just with
these two options,
the two Matt Damon movies,
Bourne Ultimatum and
Good Shepherd. And here
are the remaining payoffs,
and let's see how we play this
out.
So let's pick on some people.
Ale you want to pick on
somebody?
I've got Kai here as well.
Okay, so you've picked on
somebody there.
The person Ale picked on,
you want to stand up?
Okay, your name is?
Student: Nina.
Professor Ben Polak: Say
again loudly.
Student: Nina.
Professor Ben Polak: Ana?
Shout it out so everyone hears.
Student: Nina.
Professor Ben Polak:
Nina, okay Nina I'm sorry.
Nina and Kai get your guy to
stand up there.
And your name is?
Student: David.
Professor Ben Polak:
David so--do you know each
other?
Student: No.
Professor Ben Polak: No
you're--so you're about to go on
a date.
So Nina's preferences are
Player 1's preferences here.
So she--her best thing now is
to successfully meet David at
The Bourne Ultimatum and
David's preferences are Player
2's preferences,
so his favorite thing is to
successfully mette at The
Good Shepherd.
Why don't you write down a
second on the corner of your
notepad what it is you're going
to choose to do with my T.A.'s
watching so we can't cheat.
Both have it written down?
Should we have a good look at
them?
Should we just embarrass them a
bit?
We looked at them already I
guess.
So Nina, shout out to the crowd
what it is you've--where it is
you've chosen to go.
Student: Bourne
Ultimatum.
Professor Ben Polak:
Bourne Ultimatum;
and David where do you choose
to go?
Student: I also put down
Bourne Ultimatum.
Professor Ben Polak:
They're going to coordinate;
that's very good.
I don't know what this tells us
about David and Nina,
but don't let them off the hook
quite yet.
So now, that was good,
we managed to coordinate.
I think we can all see that we
might not have done.
Let's try some communication in
this game.
We said that coordination games
are helped by communication.
So let's imagine we're playing
the game again,
once again, you're going to the
movies,
once again the first one didn't
happen so you didn't--for some
reason it was cancelled that
night because someone had a bad
cold or something.
You are about to go off on
Friday night to see these movies
and let's allow some
communication ahead of time.
So David, you're about to go,
you realize you've got this
coordination problem,
so you phone Nina up and you
can say whatever you like,
so what would you say to Nina?
Student: Looks like you
want to go to Bourne
Ultimatum.
I'd rather go and--if you're
going to be stubborn I'd rather
go see Bourne Ultimatum
with you than not go on a date
at all.
Professor Ben Polak: So
here's another clue.
Stubborn is not a good first
date word, but okay.
So Nina what would you say in
response to that?
Student: I'll go to
Bourne Ultimatum.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, so write down what you're
going to do this time.
Nina what did you do?
Student: Bourne
Ultimatum.
Professor Ben Polak:
David?
Student: Bourne
Ultimatum.
Professor Ben Polak: So
they're still managing to
coordinate but you--okay,
so thank you for this couple,
let's give them a round of
applause.
We may come back and pick on
you later on in the course,
but we'll leave it for now.
So in this case,
the communication worked but am
I right in thinking that the
communication isn't such an
instant solution as it was in
the game we saw last time?
This game's a little bit harder
to get communication to work.
Why?
Is that right first of all?
So what's the problem here?
Why is this a slightly more
difficult game?
Let's keep the mikes handy a
second.
Why is this a more difficult
game to attain coordination in?
Student: Can I say the
best response is the Nash
Equilibrium?
Professor Ben Polak:
Well no, hang on a second.
Just slow down a second,
that's a good one.
Let's start with that.
What are the Nash Equilibria in
this game?
Somebody, let's just pick on
somebody.
Just pick on anybody okay.
Yeah, what are the Nash
Equilibria in this game?
Student: Both players
doing Bourne Ultimatum
and both players doing Good
Shepherd.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, so in fact,
if we checked the Nash
Equilibria in this game,
the Nash Equilibria,
and you can check that they are
in fact best responses,
are both people doing The
Bourne Ultimatum or both
people doing The Good
Shepherd.
And the reason for that is if
the other person's going to go
to Bourne Ultimatum I
want to do that,
and if the other person's going
to go Good Shepherd I
want to do that.
So these are both Nash
Equilibria.;
That isn't so much the problem.
That was true last time as well.
There were two well coordinated
Nash Equilibria although one was
better than the other.
What's the tricky thing here?
What's the extra trick here?
Is there a mike on this side?
There was a hand up there, yeah.
Stand up.
Great.
Student: Each player
prefers a different Nash
Equilibrium.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, so unlike the other game,
the two examples of
coordination games we saw so far
were really pure coordination
problems.
Is that right?
They were pure coordination
problems.
There was no conflict at all.
In the case of the Investor
Game last week,
every player preferred one
equilibrium to the other.
The game I just put up,
that's a trivial example,
it didn't really matter which
equilibrium we played here,
we just wanted to play an
equilibrium, is that right?
But here, there's a potential
source of conflict here.
Both people would rather be at
an equilibrium than to be
mal-coordinated or
uncoordinated,
but Player 1 wants to go to
Bourne Ultimatum and
Player 2 wants to go to Good
Shepherd,
and actually I thought Nina's
strategy there was pretty good.
Nina's version of communication
was, "I'm going to Bourne
Ultimatum."
That basically fixed things.
But you could imagine that
communication could break down
here.
There could be a negotiation
going on.
So think about--I don't want to
push this too hard but think
about other games where people
are communicating to fail--to
avoid a failure of coordination.
There's a strike negotiation
going on as we speak.
In fact, there was a critical
moment this morning up in
Detroit between General Motors
and the united autoworkers and I
don't want to say that strikes
are only about mis-coordination,
but clearly,
everyone's better off if they
come to some agreement rather
than strike.
There's at least some agreement
that's going to be better for
everybody than a strike,
and yet, because they're
conflicting interests there,
basically in that case
conflicting interest about
health and pension payments,
it could well be that you end
failing to coordinate.
So this game has a name,
and actually somebody mentioned
it last time.
Who was the person who
mentioned this last time?
Somebody mentioned this.
What was this game called?
Shout it out!
Battle of the Sexes.
That's good.
So this game's called The
Battle of the Sexes and we'll
see it in various forms over the
course of the semester.
It's actually a very
interesting game.
Games like it,
they are coordination games but
different people disagree about
where you'd like to coordinate.
So much for talking about
coordination games and helping
you with your dating strategy.
This being a Game Theory class,
there's at least one game we
have to discuss and we've come
to it now.
So we're going to spend most of
the rest of today talking about
Cournot Duopoly.
Before I do that,
let me just check.
How many of you have seen
Cournot Duopoly before?
Just raise your hands just for
me.
All right, so maybe about half
of you.
So those of you who have,
don't worry,
I mean this will be a bit
review, but we'll see it more
through the eyes of Game Theory
this time,
and for those of you who
haven't, don't worry we're going
to go through it.
So this is a classic game,
perhaps it's one of the most
famous games,
and therefore worth studying in
the class.
Now, as a purely Game Theory
exercise, one reason for
studying Cournot Duopoly,
is that so far we've discussed
how to find Nash Equilibrium
when there are few players,
each of whom has few
strategies, and we've discussed
how to find Nash Equilibrium
where there are many players,
each of whom has few
strategies, and this is a game
where there are few players,
maybe two, but they have many
strategies.
They actually have a continuum
of strategies.
For those people who aren't
familiar with this and are
worried about the economics of
it in particular,
it's gone over in considerable
detail in chapter 6 of the
textbook.
So just to motivate this a
little bit, so there's two
reasons why this game is
interesting.
This is a game in which there
are two firms who are competing
in the same market,
and we'll give a bit more
detail in a second.
One reason this game is
interesting from the point of
view of economics,
is this game lies between the
two extreme cases that you learn
about in your Intro Economics
class.
One extreme case is perfect
competition and the other
extreme case is monopoly.
So this is really the first
attempt, way back in the
nineteenth century to study a
market that's somewhere in the
middle,
where it happens most markets
are--there are two firms.
We're interested in two things
here.
We're interested in what's
going to happen in these
markets.
And then from a welfare point
of view, from a policy point of
view, we're interested about
whether this is good for
consumers or good for producers
or what.
How this relates to profits and
consumer surplus.
So with that in mind,
let's just set the game up.
So the players in this game are
two firms and the strategies in
this game for the firms--and
this is going to turn out to be
important--the strategies are
the quantities that they produce
of an identical product.
So they are the quantities they
produce, each of them produces,
of an identical product.
So as far as the consumers are
concerned, these two products
are perfect substitutes.
You could think of these as two
companies producing bottled
water--and now we're going to
get hundreds of letters saying
not all bottled waters are the
same,
especially from Italians and
the French, but never mind.
Let's just pretend that they
are.
So just to emphasize that the
strategies are quantities,
rather than using S let me use
q today to be the strategies.
So qi and q-i or q_1
and q_2 will be the
strategies.
We need to give a little bit
more structure on the payoff
before I get to the payoffs.
So in particular,
I need to tell you what is the
cost of production.
And the cost of production in
this game is simply going to be
cq.
So if I produce one unit it
costs me c;
if I produce two units it costs
me 2c;
if I produce 100 units,
it'll cost me 100c and if I
produce .735 units that costs me
.735c.
So for those people who took
Intro Economics,
which is most of you,
this is a game--this a setting
in which we have constant
marginal costs.
The constant marginal cost is c.
I'll need to tell you about how
prices are determined in this
market.
So prices are determined as
follows: prices depend on some
parameters I'm just going to
call a and b,
and let me write the equation
and then we'll see what it looks
like.
So basically the idea is that
the more these firms produce,
so the more the total quantity
produced q_1 +
q_2,
the lower is the price in the
marketplace for this product.
Let's just draw a picture of
that;
we'll come back to this in a
minute.
Let's draw a picture which we
can keep for later.
Actually, let's save myself
some time and bring this down.
So this equation I've just
written, if you can imagine
q_1 + q_2,
total quantity on the
horizontal axis,
and you could imagine price on
the vertical axis,
and basically what we're saying
is that prices depend on total
quantities as follows:
where the slope of this line is
-b.
Now, for those of you who took
Economics 115 or equivalent,
what is the name of this line
I've just drawn?
That was way fewer responses
than I wanted.
Let's try again;
what's the name of this
downward sloping (hint-hint)
line that I've just drawn?
It's a demand curve.
Thank you;
it's a demand curve.
That was the demand.
It tells me--the other way
around--to look at how prices
correspond to quantities,
it tells me the quantity
demanded at any given price.
We'll come back to that in a
second.
Meanwhile, let's just finish up
what we're doing here and put in
payoffs.
So payoffs for these firms are
going to depend on profits,
the payoffs.
The firms' aim to maximize
profit and profit is going to be
given by P times q minus--sorry,
let's do this for Firm 1.
Let's be careful here;
let's do this for Firm 1 and
we'll do Firm 2 in a second.
So the payoff for Firm 1,
as it depends on the quantity
that she produces and the
quantity that the other firm
produces,
is going to be prices times the
quantity that Firm 1 produces
minus costs times the quantity
that she produces.
So this is--this term here is
revenues and this term here is
total costs.
Revenues minus costs makes
profits, and again,
for those of you who are less
familiar with economics,
I'm hoping this is not really
too hard but you can read up on
it.
What I'm going to do here is
I'm going to substitute in for
prices.
So I've got this expression for
prices here, here it is,
and I want to plug it into that
P there.
And I'm going to rewrite it now
with that P expanded out.
So I'm going to get--I'm going
to multiply it out at the same
time, so I'm going to have
aq_1 -
bq_1²
- bq_1q_2 -
cq_1.
All I'm doing here,
nothing particularly exciting,
I'm simply plugging this
expression in for P and then I
multiplied the whole thing out
because it was all multiplied by
q.
I should warn you again that
I'm very likely to make mistakes
when I'm doing this kind of
thing, so please catch me I do.
So here I have a new expression
for Firm 1's profit and I could
do the same for Firm 2,
but I'm not going too because
it's--I'm getting bored.
So this is just Firm 1's profit.
Now, with this in hand,
what I want to do is,
and in Firm 2 I have a similar
expression,
what I want to do is,
I want to figure out the Nash
Equilibrium of this game.
Now, I will need the other
board;
I want to figure out the Nash
Equilibrium on this game.
Both firms are producing
quantities;
both firms are trying to
maximize profit,
and I want to find out the Nash
Equilibrium.
How do I go about that exercise?
What's the--what do I need to
do find each firm's Nash
Equilibrium?
How do we always find Nash
Equilibrium when we're not
guessing?
What do we do?
Anybody?
Somebody way over there who's
going to be way off camera but
we can actually get a mike in
there.
Can we get a--he's way in the
corner there.
Come this way,
a little closer to the aisle,
there you go.
Student: Well,
we would just delete the--we
would iteratively delete
dominated strategies.
Professor Ben Polak:
Okay, we could do that.
We could do that;
we could try iteratively
deleting dominated strategies
and see if that process
converged.
I had something else in mind
here, something else more
straightforward.
What else?
The guy in red.
Student: Identify the
best responses of each player as
a function of the others and
find out where they intersect.
Professor Ben Polak: Say
that loud--more--that was
correct, say it more loudly,
shout.
Student: Identify the
best responses of each player as
a function of the others and
find out where they intersect.
Professor Ben Polak:
Okay good.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to figure out Player
1's best response quantity to
each possible choice of Player
2,
and then we're going to flip it
around and figure out Player 2's
best response quantity to each
possible choice of Player 1,
and then we're going to see
where they--where those
coincide, where they cross.
So, just like we've done
several times before.
So what I need to do then is I
need to figure out what is
Player 1's best response for
each possible choice
q_2 of Player 2.
So how do I do that?
I want to find the best
response.
How do I do that?
Everyone is looking like this
is--I bet you all know really.
Anybody?
Cold call somebody?
Athletic day for you.
Somebody way at the back there;
stand up and shout.
Student: Find the best
response function by
differentiating this and
maximizing the function for
every q_2,
so we could just-- Professor
Ben Polak: Good,
so what we're going to do
is--all right good,
we're going to--we're trying to
maximize--the best response is
going to maximize these profits.
So, in particular,
what we're going to do to find
out what quantity q_1
maximizes this profits for each
choice of q_2.
We're going to differentiate
this with respect to
q_1 and then what?
And then set it equal to 0.
So again, let me just take a
look out there.
How many of you remember this?
We did this once before in this
class.
How many of you remember this
from when you were--high school
calculus days or from 112?
Quite a number of you actually.
Okay, good, so what we're going
to do is we're going to
differentiate this thing to find
a first order condition.
We're going to differentiate
with respect to q_1,
the thing we're trying--our
control variable,
the thing we're trying to
maximize the thing with respect
to and set it equal to 0.
So what are we going to get?
So this term here
aq_1 is going to
become an a and this term here
-bq² is going to become a
2bq_1 and this term
here,
-b q_1q_2
is going to become a
-bq_2,
and the last term
-cq_1 is going to
become a -c.
Everyone happy with that?
What I did was I differentiated
this fairly simple function with
respect to q_1 and
since I want to find a maximum,
what I'm going to do is I'm
going to set this thing equal to
0.
At my maximum,
I'll put a hat over it to
indicate this is the argmax;
at my maximum I'm going to set
this thing equal to 0.
Now, since we're being nerdy in
this class, despite our attempts
to go dating,
we're being nerdy,
let's actually be a little bit
careful.
This was a first order
condition or a first order
necessary condition.
I actually need to check the
second order condition.
So how do I check the second
order condition?
I differentiate again, right?
I differentiate a second time
and check the sign,
so the second order condition,
I differentiate this expression
again with respect to
q_1.
The only place q_1
appears here is here,
so when I differentiate again
I'm going to get -2b and sure
enough that's negative,
which is what I wanted to know,
just to check that when I'm
finding this thing,
I'm finding a maximum and not a
minimum.
Good, so this is our key
expression and I'm going to use
this expression;
I'm going to solve it for
q_1.
So the best response for Player
1, as a function of what Player
2 chooses, q_2,
is just equal to the
q_1 hat in this
expression and if I solve that
out carefully,
I will no doubt make a mistake,
but let's try it.
I got to have a - c over 2b -
q_2 over 2.
So try that at home,
I think I did that right.
So I took this to the other
side and I divided through by 2b
and the b here cancels.
Everyone just stare at that a
second, make sure I got it
right.
I'm very capable of getting
these things wrong.
Good, so what I have here is an
equation that tells me Player
1's best response for each
possible choice of Player 2.
I could do the same thing for
Player 2 to find Player 2's best
response for every possible
choice of Player 1.
On the other hand,
we know it's--the math is going
to be the same,
so let's cheat.
I know that Player 2's best
response for every possible
choice of Player 1,
which if we had done it would
be q_2 hat is going to
a - c over 2b--q_1
over 2,
right?
I'm just flipping around the
2's and the 1's.
So at this point I've found
Player 1's best response as a
function of q_2.
I've found Player 2's best
response as a function of
q_1,
and the way I did it,
just remember,
the way I did it was I applied
a little bit of 112 and/or high
school calculus,
so that's your single variable
calculus.
Now, we could just solve at
this point but let's not.
Let's draw these.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go back to my picture
and draw these functions.
I'll just remind us of what
these functions are;
it's a - c over 2b -
q_2 over 2 and
accordingly for Player 2.
That's the thing;
it was hidden by the board.
What I want to do is I want to
draw a picture,
a little bit like we did for
the partnership game.
So in the partnership game we
put efforts on these axis and
now I'm going to put quantities
on these axis.
So this is going to be the
choice of Player 1,
and this is going to be the
choice of Player 2,
and what I want to do is I want
to figure out what this looks
like.
For each q_2 that you
give me or that Player 2
chooses, I want to find out and
draw what is Player 1's best
response.
Everyone happy with what I'm
doing here?
So let's start somewhere;
what we're going to do is we'll
refer back to this other
picture, which is why I left it
here.
So, in particular,
what would be Player 1's best
response if Player 2 didn't
produce at all?
How do we find that?
Without worrying about the
economics of it a second,
how would we find that just as
a math exercise?
So suppose Player 2 doesn't
produce at all.
What is Player 1's best
response?
Someone read it off for me.
Why don't we cold call somebody
out, you can-- Student: a
- c over 2b.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, so shout that out.
Student: a - c over 2b.
Professor Ben Polak:
Good, so if I plug q_2
= 0 into here,
this term disappears and I just
get a - c over 2b.
What's that telling me?
Let me put the 45º
line in here.
What's that telling me is that
if Player 2 chooses not to
produce then Player 1's best
response is a - c over 2b.
Now, I claim that that
quantity, a - c over 2b actually
has another name.
What's the name of that
quantity?
What's the name of the quantity
a - c over 2b?
Once we escape the algebra just
think about it in terms of
economics.
Let's think about it a bit,
let's go back to the previous
picture.
If Player 2 is producing
nothing, then what is Player 1
effectively?
He's a monopoly;
so she's a monopolist,
so we know how to figure out
monopoly quantities from what we
did in 115 or equivalent
courses.
Let me finish the picture here;
here's my demand curve,
here's my constant marginal
cost at c, and I want to use
this picture on the left now to
figure out what the monopoly
quantity is.
Can anyone tell me--let's cold
call somebody again.
Raise your hand if you took
115,110 or 150.
No, no, I know more of you took
it than that.
It's a pre-req for the class,
right?
Raise your hands if you didn't
take any of those things.
Ale, keep your hands up.
Cold call somebody who hasn't
got their hand up.
Anybody, go ahead.
Do you want to tell me what
the--where's the monopoly
quantity on this picture?
The woman--where you are--the
woman here.
Student: Oh no I really
don't remember.
Professor Ben Polak:
Don't remember.
Student: I'm sorry.
Professor Ben Polak: Who
else doesn't remember?
Somebody must--don't remember
is a good reply if you're
auditioning to be the Attorney
General, but it's not such a
good reply--anybody?
Somebody help me out here,
where's the monopoly quantity
on this picture?
It's a good review exercise,
yeah.
Student: It's where the
marginal revenue is equal to the
marginal costs.
Professor Ben Polak:
It's where marginal revenue
equals marginal cost.
I should have picked on some of
the SOM people by the way.
It's where marginal revenue
equals marginal cost,
right?
The reason I should pick on the
SOM people, is their ambition in
life is to run a monopoly,
right.
Trouble is I haven't drawn the
marginal revenue curve yet.
Right, you can't actually see
the marginal revenue here.
What does the marginal revenue
look like in this picture?
Why don't we go to the same
guy, the guy in brown.
Where's the marginal
revenue--what's the marginal
revenue look like in this
picture on the left?
Student: It's half the
slope of the price.
Professor Ben Polak:
Yeah, or it's--I guess it's
twice the slope but that's fair
enough.
I know what you mean.
So the marginal revenue here,
let's put it in a different
color, the marginal revenue
looks something like this and
as--I don't know what your name
is--as the guy said,
the monopoly quantity is when
marginal revenue equals marginal
costs.
As we know, this line here has
twice the slope of the original
line of the demand curve,
so the slope of this thing is
-2b.
Now, I'm going to claim that
this monopoly quantity I claimed
before is going to--our
intuition says if the other firm
isn't producing,
my best response must be to
produce monopoly quantity which
I can see on this picture,
and I also claim that the math
is telling me,
just a kind of nerdy math is
telling me,
that that quantity is a - c
over 2b and I claim that they're
the same thing.
How can I see they're the same
thing?
Well look, here I have a line
of slope -2.
How far down does it have to go?
It has to a - c down.
This pink line has to drop off
from a all the way to c.
How far along do I have to go
drop off a - c when I have slope
-2b?
Answer a - c over 2b.
Not even calculus - all you
need is high school.
So this monopoly quantity is
indeed a - c over 2b.
I'm going to ask again,
is some of this being--coming
out of the fog?
I mean, you may not understand
it with algebra before but some
of these sorts of pictures have
you seen before?
It's good review exercise for
some of you who are--who have
taken 115 or are about to take
150 or are there now.
So we found precisely one point
on this best response picture,
and there's a lot of points to
find, and it's 20 past 12,
so we better get going.
So let's try and find another
point.
Let's ask a different question.
How much quantity would Firm 2
have to produce in order to
induce Firm 1 not to produce at
all?
Again, how much quantity would
Firm 2 have to produce in order
to induce Firm 1's best response
to be 0?
Help me out--it's Katie.
Is that right?
The woman in green,
let's get a mike to Katie.
Or, there's a mike close by.
Student: a - c over 2b.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, so that's just solving
out the algebra,
so we're saying what's--what q
solves, a - c over 2b -
q_2 over 2 = 0.
What q_2 makes this
equal to 0 and Katie's answer is
solving out the algebra here is
that q_2 that solves
this must be a - c over b.
That's right;
where can I see that one on the
picture though?
Let's go back to the economics.
So I'm claiming that there's
some quantity up here.
I claim this quantity is a - c
over b such that if Firm 2
produces that much quantity,
Firm 1 will just produce
nothing.
But that's just kind of algebra
and math.
Where can I see it on this
picture?
What quantity,
if produced by Firm 2,
would cause Firm 1 to shut down
on this picture?
Let's get a mike in here.
Student: That's where
the marginal cost and the demand
thing, demand lines intersect.
Professor Ben Polak: So
it's here right,
it's here.
It's where marginal--it's where
the marginal cost and the demand
curve intersects.
What's the intuition?
Let's work it out.
Suppose Firm 2 has produced all
of this quantity up to here.
So Firm 2 is already producing
all of this quantity.
So already, just from Firm 2's
production the price has been
driven all the way down to
costs.
So if I--I'm Firm 1--if I
produce any more quantity,
what's going to happen to the
price?
I produce any quantity at all
in addition to what's out there
already, what's going to happen
to the price?
It's going to be pushed below
costs.
So I'll be producing this
stuff, this water at cost c and
only getting p,
which is not only less than c
in return.
So I'll be losing money on any
product that I produce.
Does everyone see that?
Let me say it again.
So Firm 2--if Firm 2 produces
all the way up to here then any
product produced by Firm 1 is
going to push prices even lower.
In particular,
they'll be lower here than
costs and so you'll make losses
on that product.
What's the name--going back to
Economics 115--what's the name
for this quantity?
The quantity where demand and
marginal costs equal--that's the
competitive quantity.
So this is the perfect
competition quantity.
In a perfectly competitive
market that's exactly where
prices are going to end up.
This is not a perfectly
competitive market,
but if it were,
that's where price is going to
end up.
So we have the monopoly
quantity here,
and we have the competitive
here, and in between what does
this best response curve look
like?
Somebody?
It's a straight line, thank you.
So in between--this is just a
straight line.
So here is the best response of
Firm 1 to each possible choice
of Firm 2.
Everyone's looking really like
this was hard,
but it can't be that hard.
Most of you have seen this
before.
If you haven't seen it before
don't panic.
All I did was,
I did a little bit of calculus,
a little bit of algebra,
and then I drew the thing.
Okay, so this is Firm 1's best
response as a function of
q_2.
What is Firm 2's best response
as a function of q_1?
Let's just--we'll get there,
just to remind you,
the way we read this is you
give me a quantity of Firm 2,
I find Firm 1's best response
by going across to the pink line
and dropping down.
So if Firm 2 produces this
amount then Firm 1's best
response is this amount.
If Firm 2 produces this amount
then Firm 1's best response is
this amount.
Now conversely,
how do we find Firm 2's best
response as a function of
q_1?
What does that look like?
Those two guys in front of you.
Student: It's
Professor Ben Polak:
Shout it out.
Student: It's
symmetrical across the 45º
axis.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, it's reflected across the
45º line.
So let's reflect these two
points.
This will be here;
this will be--I've got to be a
bit more careful.
Missed by a mile,
let me try again.
I missed by a mile,
which is a problem in drawing
my lines, but never mind.
So this will be the monopoly
quantity for Firm 2 and this is
the competitive quantity of Firm
1.
So if I had drawn that better
it would look as if this was
half of this distance,
but I didn't draw it well.
Try and draw it better in your
notes.
So this is a - c over b and
this is a - c over 2b so this
distance and this distance are
meant to be the same.
The way I've drawn it they're
not the same at all.
The way we read this green
graph is you give me a choice of
Firm 1, q_1.
I go up to the green line and
go across and this tells me the
best response for Firm 2.
So at this point,
how many of you have seen this
picture before?
A good many of you have seen it
before.
So I think we can really cold
call somebody for this one.
So somebody tell me--pick
somebody to cold--why don't you
call a person,
anybody that goes by.
There we go, okay.
So here's the tough question.
What's the Nash Equilibrium on
this picture?
Student: Where the green
and the pink line intersect.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, where the green and the
pink line intersect.
So this must be the Nash
Equilibrium, that wasn't hard,
right?
Okay now--so why--let's go back
again.
Why is this the Nash
Equilibrium?
Because at this point,
as in the partnership game,
which there was a similar
thing,
as in the partnership game
where the best responses
intersect is where Player 1 is
playing a best response to
Player 2,
and Player 2 is playing a best
response to Player 1.
So this is the Nash Equilibrium
in this Cournot game.
Let's do a little bit of
algebra just to make sure we can
find this thing.
So what we're going to do is
set these two things equal to
each other, put in stars here.
So at the Nash Equilibrium
quantities I'm going to have
q_1* is equal to a - c
over 2bq* and q_2* is
equal to a - c 2bq_1*
over 2 and now we're going to
solve this out by setting
q_1 = q_2
since I know the game is
symmetric and they were on the
45º line.
So what I have to do here to do
this algebraically is to solve
out these equations.
So let's try and do that.
So putting q_1 in
here--if I substitute
q_1 in here,
what will that give me?
It'll give me q_1* is
equal to a - c over 2b -
q_1* over 2.
Let's multiply both sides by 2,
I'll get 2q_1* is
equal to a - c over b -
q_1*.
Take that to the other side.
I have 3 q_1* is
equal to a - c over b;
and finally divide by 3
q_1* is equal to a - c
over 3b.
So that crossing point actually
occurs at a - c over 3b.
I'm going to look desperately
at my T.A.'s to make sure I
didn't screw that up.
So this is something that's
called the Cournot quantity.
Now, this game,
this game of imperfect
competition between two firms
competing in quantities,
was thought up and studied by a
French economist called Cournot
almost a hundred years before
Nash.
So a hundred years really
before the invention of Game
Theory, someone had figured out
this answer for this game.
Okay, so what do we know so far?
I'll leave the algebra there,
transfer it up here,
q_1* = q_2*
= a - c over 3b.
So, so far, we've been working
pretty hard and we haven't,
I guess, learned a lot,
we've just kind of solved the
thing out.
Now, we get to draw some
lessons out of this thing,
so everybody who's feeling a
little bit shell shocked from
having been doing algebra and
calculus and drawing pictures
and feeling like they've been
cheated into taking a class that
looks far too much like
economics,
calm down we're going to
actually talk right now.
So, one thing to remark about
this game, one thing that we've
learned immediately,
is that this game is different
in a significant way.
It's different from the
partnership game.
I mean, obviously it's
different because it's about
something different,
but I mean in terms of the Game
Theory it's different.
It's different from the
partnership game,
it's different from the
investment game.
What is it that's different
about this game from the--what's
the obvious thing just looking
at this picture that makes it
different from the partnership
game?
In the partnership game the
best response lines sloped up.
The more I did of my strategy,
the more the other player did
as a best response.
In the investment game,
the more likely I was to
invest, the more likely you--the
more you wanted to invest.
But in this game we have the
exact opposites.
The more Player 1 produces,
the less Player 2 wants to
produce and the more Player 2
produces, the less Player 1
wants to produce.
So this game is a game,
not of strategic complements,
but of strategic substitutes.
I want to be careful here.
It's not that these goods are
substitutes.
I mean, clearly that's also the
case, right?
If both these firms are
producing bottled water and it's
identical, then the goods
themselves are substitutes.
That's not the point I'm making
here.
Strategic substitutes is a
strategy--is a statement about
the nature of the game.
So strategic substitutes is
telling me that my strategy is a
strategic substitute of your
strategy if the more I do at my
strategy,
the less you want to do of
yours and conversely,
the more you want to do of your
strategy,
the less I want to do of mine.
Now, let's come back to the
question we started with,
which has to do with profits
and so on in society.
We know that if these players
play these games,
at least if we believe in Nash
Equilibrium,
then they're going to produce
these quantities,
they're going to produce here.
But let's ask a different
question.;
Each of these firms is trying
to maximize profits,
but how about the total profit
in the industry?
Each of these firms--we know
the fact that they're playing
best response--is maximizing
their profits taking as giving
what the other firm is doing.
But how about total industry
profits?
Are they being maximized here?
Who thinks total industry
profits are being maximized?
profits are not being maximized?
All right, good;
shout out.
Total industry profits are not
being maximized.
Where on the picture--let me do
a bit more cold calling
here--where on the picture
maximizes total industry
profits?
We had him before?
No idea?
You're taking the fifth here?
The guy in there, yeah.
Student: Is it at the
monopoly?
Professor Ben Polak:
Monopoly, exactly.
So clearly, if we produce the
monopoly quantity,
by definition,
the monopoly quantity maximizes
total industry profits.
For example,
if Firm 2 shut down and Firm 1
produced its monopoly profits,
that is, a monopoly quantity,
that would maximize firm
profits.
Conversely, if Firm 1 shut down
and Firm 2 produced its monopoly
quantity that would maximize
industry profits.
Where else in this picture
maximizes industry profits?
So this point maximized
industry profits and this point
maximizes industry profits.
Where else maximizes industry
profits?
Anybody?
Well, how about all the points
in between?
Here, Firm 1 produced nothing
and Firm 2 produced a monopoly
quantity;
and here Firm 2 produced
nothing and Firm 1 produced a
monopoly quantity.
But you could also just split
the monopoly quantity,
for example,
half half at this point here.
So if the firms wanted to make
more money, the only thing they
could do is they could sign an
agreement saying,
why don't each of us produce
not our Cournot quantity,
but produce half monopoly
profits.
I'm sorry, half the monopoly
quantity and that would produce
this much each.
So Firm 1 would be producing
half its monopoly quantity and
Firm 2 would be producing half
its monopoly quantity.
So what's wrong with that
agreement?
What are they?
They're two water companies,
so they're Poland Spring and
Coca-Cola I guess these days,
sign this agreement saying that
each one's going to produce half
monopoly quantity and what's
going to go wrong with that
agreement?
The guy in red.
Student: First of all
it's illegal.
Professor Ben Polak:
It's illegal.
So even without there being an
Attorney General,
somebody might be awake in the
justice department and notice
that that's actually illegal.
It's illegal to sign an
agreement--to sign a contract
saying you're going to restrict
quantities.
It's illegal,
so they can't sign that as a
contract, but they they can just
agree to do it.
So Coca-Cola and Poland Spring
could just agree to produce half
the quantity of water each.
What's going to go--what might
go wrong in that agreement?
Let's just suppose that that
game's just been played once for
now.
Suppose that this is
Coca-Cola's quantity and this is
Poland Spring's quantity,
and suppose you're the manager
of Poland Spring,
so water is coming out of the
ground in Maine for you and you
know that this Coca-Cola guy is
going to produce this quantity
here,
so this is q^(M) over 2.
So let's pick on our two
managers;
let's have two people who have
spoken before,
so the guy in the red shirt's
name is?
Student: Steve.
Professor Ben Polak:
Steve, and I guess in red he
should be the Coca-Cola guy,
and let's pick on our Jimmy
Stewart from last week,
whose name is Patrick.
Can I get a mike in on Patrick?
So Steve and Patrick are
respectively the managers of
Coca-Cola and Poland Spring and
Patrick believes that the
Coca-Cola manager is going
to--may be we should just make
this Coke and Pepsi since two
identical--they're near enough
and identical,
right?
So these are Coke and Pepsi,
that will confuse me less.
So Patrick, our manager of
Pepsi believes that Coca-Cola is
going to produce this quantity
and he's agreed to produce this
quantity.
What is Patrick actually going
to do?
Patrick, what are you going to
do?
Student: So I should
cheat and pick the quantity on
my best response line that's
much farther out so I'll produce
more than my quantity.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, so Patrick (being Jimmy
Stewart or not,
actually) when he's in
the--when he's playing the
manager of Pepsi he's going to
produce more of this undrinkable
liquid and produce this quantity
here.
So what is this?
This is Patrick's best response
to the other guy producing the
monopoly quantity.
So Patrick's response in Pepsi
is to overproduce relative to
the monopoly quantity,
actually overproduce even
relative to the Cournot quantity
and produce all the way out
here.
Okay, so Patrick's producing
here but what about Mr.
Coca-Cola guy?
Now, Mr.
Coca-Cola guy knows Patrick
pretty well, they've been in the
same industry for a while and
Mr.
Coca-Cola guy,
whose name is?
Student: Steven.
Professor Ben Polak:
Steven.
Steven presumably knows that
Patrick is actually going to
produce this quantity--I'm sorry
this quantity.
So Steven, what should you
produce?
Student: Increase my own
production to match my best
response line.
Professor Ben Polak:
Good, so Steven,
anticipating that Patrick is
going to think that Steven's a
sucker but Patrick's going to
cheat on him and produce too
much,
Steven's going to produce a
best response to that and he's
going to produce this quantity
here.
So what is this?
This is Player 2's best
response, so Player 1's best
response to Player 2 producing
half monopoly output.
But Patrick knows Steven pretty
well;
he knows those guys who run
Coca-Cola are pretty smart guys,
so Patrick knows that the guy
who runs Coca-Cola is going to
anticipate that the guy who runs
Pepsi is going to cheat on the
guy who runs Coca-Cola,
and hence the guy who runs
Coca-Cola is going to play a
best response to Patrick's cheat
on quantity.
So what quantity is Patrick
going to produce?
Student: I'll increase
my production then;
I'll be pretty close to the
Cournot equilibrium.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, so you're going to go to
here;
so this point here is--I can't
even write this.
This is the best response of
Player 1 to the best response of
Player 2, to the best response
of Player 1 to Player 2
producing half monopoly output
and there are lots of brackets
here.
Can anyone see where this
process is going?
It's going back to the Nash
Equilibrium.
Each of them is trying to play
a best response for what they
anticipate the other person's
going to do.
And in this game if they keep
on doing that,
it's going to drag them back to
Nash Equilibrium.
But I want to be careful here.
This won't be true of all games.
But in this game,
playing best response to each
other, figuring out that in fact
the other guy is going to cheat
on me,
or the other guy is
anticipating that I'm going to
cheat on him,
or the other guy is going to
anticipate that I'm going to
anticipate that he's going to
cheat on me,
etc., etc., will eventually
drag us back to the Cournot
quantity.
So it's going to be pretty
difficult for us to sustain this
joint monopoly output,
this collusive agreement.
We can't let the courts enforce
it.
We're Coca-Cola and Pepsi,
so we really don't want to have
to bring the mafia in,
although maybe we do,
I don't know.
So basically,
we're stuck with this verbal
agreement and we both have an
incentive to cheat and produce
more whatever it is,
sugar water.
Now, in practice,
this is not the only problem
facing two firms who are trying
to produce the monopoly output.
In practice,
when firms try and have these
agreements, which are not
contracts, to try and produce
joint monopoly output,
what else goes wrong?
So you can imagine some firms
trying to have an agreement.
We know they can't sign a legal
agreement, but let's take that
off the table.
So, for example,
in around 1900 in America or a
little bit earlier,
let's say 1880 in America,
it really isn't clear that it
was illegal to write agreements
to say we'll restrict
quantities.
So firms did use to write that
kind of agreements,
but still something went wrong.
What went wrong?
So we're getting a little bit
further away from the game and
more back into the real world.
What kind of things went wrong?
I want to get somebody who's
near a mike.
Can I get the woman here with
the Yale shirt?
Student: Without a
contract there's no means of
enforcement.
Professor Ben Polak: All
right, so it might be
that--again, the problem with
enforcement--although actually
in 1880 America,
it's not clear that they
couldn't have enforced that
contract.
So one problem is
unenforceability but that
might--far off ago that might
have been a problem.
What else?
The guy next to her.
Student: If they're not
at the competitive output they
could undercut price and take
the entire market.
Professor Ben Polak:
Let's be careful.
We'll come back to that next
time, but right now we're
competing in quantities.
So we're not fixing prices
here, we're not even naming
price.
We're just producing Coca-Cola
and Pepsi and for want of a
better word, spewing it out into
the market.
What else goes wrong here?
Well, one thing that goes wrong
is that suppose Coke and Pepsi
were able to--either to write a
contract or whatever--to sustain
joint monopoly output at this
high price,
this price which is
actually--producing positive
profits in the industry--it is
going to turn out,
therefore the price is going to
be above costs.
These firms're making all the
profits, what do you thinks
going to happen in this
industry?
This industry that's got a lot
of profit around it,
what's going to happen in this
industry?
Yeah, the guy in the blue shirt
here;
Ale this guy here.
Student: Another
competitor could join the
market.
Professor Ben Polak:
Another firm is going to come in
and produce a similar product.
So Dr.
Pepper or something,
is there one?
Someone else is going to come
in and produce cola in this
industry and that's exactly what
happened in the U.S.
at the turn of the last century.
Companies did produce
agreements to restrict,
for example,
the production of paper and the
production of rubber,
and the production of steel,
and the production of iron,
and the production of railway
lines,
actually, even quite
complicated things.
Sure enough what you see very
quickly emerging is new entrants
entering the market to say,
hey these firms are restricting
their quantities,
we can get in there and make
money.
So new and a competitive fringe
of firms is going to enter and
drive prices down.
Now, I'm talking about 1900
America where has that happened
in the twentieth century more
dramatically?
We know the early example in
sort of Golden Age America,
but where else did we see a
competitive fringe enter when
there was a collusive agreement
to keep prices--to keep
quantities down?
Student: Airlines.
Professor Ben Polak:
Good, so airlines is an example;
we've seen that.
Where else?
Oil is probably the classic
example.
Airlines is a good example.
Okay, so in oil we all know
that in the late 60s,
early 70s, OPEC was formed
precisely to restrict quantity
among the major oil producing
countries,
and very quickly we see
companies take--other countries
take advantage of this to start
producing oil profitably.
So who were the competitive
fringe against OPEC?
Anybody?
The Brits were for a start,
the Brits--England sort
of--Scotland I should say.
Britain anyway started
producing oil in the North Sea;
lots of countries in Latin
America started looking and
finding oil, and of course,
Russian oil started being very,
very profitable.
So there are various reasons
why it's hard to maintain this
collusive agreement.
One is there's an incentive to
cheat and another is that other
firms are going to enter.
Before we leave this,
let's just pose the question we
started with.
Suppose, in fact,
we do end up back at the
Cournot quantity.
So here we are back at the
How does this quantity compare
and how do therefore the prices
compare, and how do profits
compare with monopoly prices on
the one hand,
and competitive prices on the
other?
So we know the quantity that's
going to be produced.
We figured that out;
here it is.
We know the quantities going to
be produced.
Each firm is going to produce a
- c over 3b and there are two
such firms.
So the total quantity produced
in the market--the total
quantity will be 2a - c over 3b.
How does that compare to the
monopoly quantity?
Well, the monopoly quantity was
a - c over 2b and the
competitive quantity was a - c
over b, just to remind you of
those, they're on our picture.
Here's a - c over 2b and here's
a - c over b.
So this is the total quantity
produced on this equilibrium,
in this Cournot Nash
Equilibrium.
How did it compare to the
monopoly quantity and to the
competitive quantity?
Anybody?
Just staring at the board,
which is of these is bigger?
So I claim that this total
quantity being produced is less
than the competitive quantity,
but more in total than the
monopoly quantity.
I was about to get them the
wrong way around.
Total quantity being produced
is less than would be produced
under perfect competition,
but more than would be produced
under monopoly.
Consequently,
prices are going to go the
other way and consequently
prices are going to be highest
under monopoly,
lowest on the competition,
and somewhere in between in
this Cournot situation.
So from the point of view of
the producers,
this Cournot Equilibrium is
worse than monopoly,
but better than perfect
competition.
And from the point of view of
the rest of us,
the consumers,
this Cournot quantity is worse
than perfect competition but
better than monopoly.
The only rider on that being,
if they're producing Coca-Cola
and you have any kind of concern
for your teeth,
maybe you shouldn't produce so
much anyway.
So, so far what we've done is
we've looked at this sort of
classic, I admit not the most
exciting game in the world,
but classic application of Game
Theory to imperfect competition.
Next time I'm actually going to
take this a bit further but I'm
going to leave this game behind
and look at other ways in which
we could study imperfect
competition using Game Theory.